Everybody complains about meetings...
...but it can be a really great opportunity to stand out...
...and raise your profile with your boss and your colleagues.
Of course, there is a downside to speaking up in meetings.
You don't want to interrupt people or come across as a blowhard...
...and you could look like a wallflower if you don't say anything at all.
Here's how you can really stand out in meetings.
First, do some prep work.
You've been invited to the meeting for a reason...
...and if you don't know the reason, maybe you shouldn't go to the meeting.
But prepare a few talking points so you don't get nervous about what you're saying...
...and it'll prompt you too.
Like Sheryl Sandberg said, you want to lean in and get a seat at the table.
Put your hands on the table.
You're gonna look more confident and be more involved in the conversation that way.
It's great if you sit across from the most important person in the room.
That way, when they look up, you're gonna be the first person they see.
You want to come across confidently at the meeting.
Speak up and don't undermine yourself with phrases like,...
"Well, this may be a crazy idea" or "This is just my opinion."
Be one of the first people to speak.
If you're nervous, you'll get those butterflies out of your stomach.
And you won't be so worried about what other people say...
...or someone stealing your idea or your thoughts.